la plongée du jour ressemble à première
vue à n'importe quel autre plongée un
spot des palmes des bouteilles rien de
très spécial en soit si ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les fonds
marins que ses plongeurs vont admirer
ils vont plutôt essayer de les nettoyer
pour cette première édition nettoyage
des fonds marins
si le littoral des anses d'arlet qui a
été choisie en transe dufour et ans noir
avant des zones potentielles connaîtront
un potentiel de déchets on a pris les
points gps
[Musique]
sous l'eau des centaines de déchets de
la nasse abandonné aux bouteilles en
passant par des objets en plastique
autant d'éléments polluants qui stagne
dans l'eau et qui représente un
véritable danger pour l'écosystème sous
marins
voir sortir
rota qu'on a fait de
et le gros tas de déchets ressemble à ça
la récolte d'une matinée de plonger un
travail long et fastidieux
alors pour aider les plongeurs
professionnels des apnéistes sont venus
prêter main-forte sont pas la
possibilité de remonter de redescendre
en surface descente et leurs ventes et
donc non les apnéistes on peut descendre
pour à des profondeurs de 20 30 mètres
sans problème et pouvoir faire des
allers retours l'initiative est donc née
d'un constat les fonds marins et les
littoraux martiniquais sont beaucoup
trop polluée alors il fallait mettre en
place des actions pour à la fois
dépollué à petite échelle mais aussi et
surtout sensibiliser tout un chacun
le but du jeu c'est de ces d'avoir à
faire ce genre d'opération le plus
souvent possible le plus fréquemment
possible
d'un autre côté on aimerait ne pas avoir
à le faire si on avait à ne pas le faire
ça voudrait dire que la partie nick se
porterait mieux qu'ils auraient moins de
déchets donc on espère qu'un jour on
aura plus à faire ce genre de mission
l'association et murray multiplier ce
type d'action est pas qu aux anses
d'arlet mais pour cela il faudrait
davantage de moyens et de bénévoles